Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
You know that I see a piece of fluid and I
can’t resist making videos about it…I
just can’t.
Oh my goodness.
Look at that.
These animations were created using the Material
Point Method, or MPM in short, which is a
hybrid simulation method which is able to
simulate not only substances like water and
honey, but it can also simulate snow, granular
solids, cloth, and many-many other amazing
things that you see here.
Before you ask, the hybrid part means that
it both uses particles and grids during the
computations.
Unfortunately, it is very computationally
demanding, so it takes forever to get these
simulations ready.
And typically, in my simulations, after this
step is done, I almost always find that the
objects did not line up perfectly, so I can
start the whole process again.
Ah well.
This technique has multiple stages, uses multiple
data structures in many of them, and often
we have to wait for the results of one stage
to be able to proceed to the next.
This is not that much of a problem if we seek
to implement this on our processor, but it
would be way, way faster if we could run it
on the graphics card…as long as we implement
these problems on them properly.
However, due to these stages waiting for each
other, it is immensely difficult to use the
heavy parallel computing capabilities of the
graphics card.
So here you go, this technique enables running
MPM on your graphics card efficiently, resulting
in an up to ten-time improvement over previous
works.
As a result, this granulation scene has more
than 6.5 million particles on a very fine
grid and can be simulated in only around 40
seconds per frame.
And not only that, but the numerical stability
of this technique is also superior to previous
works, and it is thereby able to correctly
simulate how the individual grains interact
in this block of sand.
Here is a more detailed breakdown of the number
of particles, grid resolutions, and the amount
of computation time needed to simulate each
time step.
I am currently in the middle of a monstrous
fluid simulation project and oh man, I wish
I had these numbers for the computation time.
This gelatin scene takes less than 7 seconds
per frame to simulate with a similar number
of particles.
Look at that heavenly gooey thing.
It probably tastes like strawberries.
And if you enjoyed this video and you wish
to help us teach more people about these amazing
papers, please consider supporting us on Patreon.
In return, we can offer you early access to
these episodes, or you can also get your name
in the video description of every episode
as a key supporter.
You can find us at Patreon.com/TwoMinutePapers.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!